ce soir on a eu notre miss france pour
toi voici sonia rolland
bâle plaint de la campagne annonce un
tube binoche sonia rolland bon comment
ça va ça va très bien une fois dans
l'humanitaire bossi là on vient de créer
une association s'appelle sonia rolland
pour les enfants parce qu'on va en faire
une fondation et elle est très jeune et
a commencé à s'installer quoi vous
occuper des enfants du rwanda
oui je commence par le rwanda parce que
parce que c'est mon pays aussi signer là
bas j'étais à kigali en 1981 oui je te
retourner à kigali ces derniers temps
j'y suis retourné à peu près 4 5 mois un
truc comme ça commence et ben c'est
mieux c'est stable de toute façon ça va
je vais rassurer tout le monde c'est
stable
les gens vivent ils sont très
accueillants et ils ont beaucoup
d'espoir ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment beau j'étais vraiment très fier
de retourner là-bas en plus ils m'ont
fait ils m'ont accueilli comme une
princesse et puis en même temps ils
disaient que j'étais un peu l'espoir en
europe
plein de choses moi j'étais assez assez
honoré parce que c'est même le président
qui disent que j'étais contente à lui
dans vous avez du mal à me de fontenay a
vendu son affaire
c'est pas elle qui la vendit déjà point
je voudrais dire ça je pense que c'est
pas elle qui l'a vendu que mais elle
détient elle tient encore plaint elle
détient encore pas mal de points là
dedans alors elle est venue ici
geneviève très très choquée douze hauts
revenus sur tous les murs de paris
elle était choquée montant que moi il
comprendre parce que les gens sont pas
très au courant de ce qui s'est passé
avec ce magazine bon évidemment on m'a
vu dénudée mais c'étaient des photos qui
étaient destinés à mon book de
mannequins et donc le photographe ou je
ne sais pas qui s'est débrouillé pour
pourra voir ces photos
l'équipe du magazine je les rencontre un
jour et me disent oui nous aimerions
faire une couverture avec vous j'ai
redit non bah non parce que le genre de
cabas de magazines ne m'intéresse pas du
tout pour faire une couverture c'est pas
intéressant du tout pour moi
en plus vous savez que j'ai une
association mais bon en même temps c'est
je me suis bien fait piéger passé je
leur ai dit non ce jour-là et une
semaine après je me balade sur les
champs et je vois des photos partout
placardés de mètres sur 2 mètres sonia
rolland se dévoile
c'est vraiment moi j'ai appelé tout de
suite geneviève parce que je me suis dit
la pauvre va être être triste oui c'est
triste de se faire avoir je suis naïve
mais en même temps vous savez que quand
on tombe sur des cons comme maire je
vous est arrivé de faire piéger comme ça
vaut bien qu'on fait d'aider des scènes
nues dans les films les journalistes
c'est ce qui vous intéresse en premier
donc l'interview au enfin dix ans les
80% l'interview c'est là dessus et puis
20% c'est sur notre vie privée ou ce
qu'on aime cuisiner ou parfois on peut
dire que les chaussures le film quand
même j'exagère enfin au départ c'était
un peu ça ouais ouais mais je suis en
procès avec pas bon donc il faut bien
savoir je suis en procès a vécu j'ai un
avocat qui est très très gentil très
fort aussi très vicieux peut-être plus
vicieux que et je pense que vous allez
faire du cinéma maintenant oui
d'ailleurs je suis très doux nom trouvé
avec binoche passe quand même grande
actrice
voilà donc vous avez là 18 ans et j'ai
joué dans un film au japon richesse
nationale
c'est quoi l'histoire l'a en fait j'ai
joué le rôle d'une prostituée dont quand
on passe de cette affaire le mystère des
univers quelle naïveté en commun
madonna ou à deux vous allez sûrement
sur moi que déçu parce que dans ce film
on voit rien du tout moi j'ai vu le
montage est assaisonné de nous voir
jouer c'est vachement impressionnant
il paraît qu'à vous avez vraiment pleuré
oui alors le réalisateur il continue à
tourner et vous l'a dit coupez use a
pris dans ses bras c'est ridicule non
parce que ça c'était surtout à l'essai
je me souviens que j'avais j'avais une
épreuve quand même pour moi parce que
pleurer face à un acteur que je
connaissais pas je savais pas comment ça
marche et j'ai jamais pris de cours de
comédie donc je ne sais pas du tout
comment ça marche comment mettre en
marche des émotions je sais pas après je
prenne vraiment des cours là dessus et
puis bah à ce moment là il m'a dit
penser à quelque chose qui t'a sûrement
fait très mal et puis à venir et là j'ai
commencé à avoir les larmes aux yeux et
puis il a dû couper et puis m'a pris
dans ses bras et m'a dit sénat a rejeté
comporte
je sais quoi le prochain le prochain
enfin je peux faire pas dire pour
l'instant c'est une surprise j'espère
que ça va marcher puis j'espère que des
réalisateurs pour être vraiment être
charmé on va voir ce qu'il y en a un qui
sort au mois d'octobre surviendrait oui
d'ailleurs vous avez été très
sympathiques avec moi c'est pas fini
on souhaite aujourd'hui on va faire une
interview opinion publique
à
à voir si vous êtres accord avec la
majorité des français
gt ça serait bien dans 69 % des couples
en france c'est la femme qui fait le
ménage
comment c'était chez vos vins et moi des
fois ya la femme de ménage de dire mais
comme je suis souvent pas là c'est pas
lui non c'est un petit côté macho si des
fois ils aident des x y z
il est des îles et des oui oui je vais
pas aborder ce sujet mais là c'est vous
qui bat non mais bon je vais pas en
parler
ben vaut mieux voir parler non c'est un
peu triste sire et voilà 73 % des
couples c'est la femme qui fait la
cuisine est chez vous comment c'était
parce que j'aime ça j'aime ça je voulais
pas dire ça non c'est pas si futile et
11e jeux nuit le ménage et la cuisine
j'aime la cuisine
sonia 38% des sables ou vous faire faire
l'amour au réveil et 73 au coucher chez
vous c'est comment je suis pas contre
les 2 56% des femmes préfèrent faire
l'amour dans le noir
ben chez vous comment c'était six mois
comment c'était moi j'aime bien voir le
regard quand même pour 34% des femmes
sait où il veut quand il veut
ah non moi je suis peut-être pas je fais
pas partie de soirée 34 ans j'ai des
titres ainsi at il lieu
je ne dirais pas non mais vous avez
remarqué
ah oui